passed away but
you know he he did play 186 against
karpov when karpov was world champion
and he bamboozled karpov
and uh he won the game i think it was d4
a6 maybe e4 i i should know this
um but then i think the story goes after
that karpov didn't want to play in any
of the same tournaments or didn't want
to play tony ever again because you know
it's a little bit when you're world
champion and someone does a6 against you
i mean if someone played a6 against you
in a in an in an important game would
you be happy or would you be like come
on man come on what are you doing would
you be insulted
[Music]
no no no i would be so cool
thank you okay
thank you for playing a bad move yeah so
but it's not that bad i mean okay it's
not quite
quite bad but i mean it's not super
terrible i guess
but you know there was an interesting
story told to me by gary kasparov that
the night after
karpa flows this game to miles
he
entered the room of karpov's coaches
and they
had a position on the board d4 a6 bishop
g5
uh they were seriously analyzing it so
next time karpov would be armed
[Music]
onto the chief but it's like actually
actually thinking about it white has a
great tromposity now yeah